do you feel like like
doing that interview did it cost you
anything
um i'm pretty sure it cost me
a few friends
um
i'm really not bothered by a lot of
people because i'm really a loner type
dude
my close friends have called me
and got on me i think the one that they
got on me the most
right is birdman
yeah you know i you know i'm a dude to
keep it 100. you know ain't nobody
bigger than the politics that's my
brother and we get on each other but
birdman out of everybody
birdman had got on my ass like
on me he told me how
dissatisfied he is i love you you my
brother i ain't never going against you
you know that we didn't been in the
trenches together
but god damn it just the way i feel what
did he say no he just told me he said
who you are and what you stand for what
you represent is greater than bigger
than that
right so you know at the end of the day
some people got that lane with me you
know i mean where they can call me and
i'm i'm gonna humble myself and i'm
gonna listen you know what i'm saying
because i got that respect for them they
they earned that from me you know what i
mean i got a few of my brothers i ain't
heard nothing from
you know what i'm saying and eventually
i hear something from but maybe i won't
you know what i mean but um
i know what my mission and my goal is
and what i'm doing people going to take
it and they're going to paint the
perception that they want to paint
around it